[Applause]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage yeah it's
that little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that
after they group to be classy after they
just it's a big old piece of trash I'm
your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toties in a new edition she's upstairs
with the snowplow guy okay don't ask any
questions keep it moving radio is very
loud up there my co-host is coming at
you from right next to me he's the CEO
of Ru garbage he's International
businessman and he is the gummy bear
bandit look out for KJ Kevin James Ryan
what up gang thanks for tuning and as
always as always please make sure you
rate you subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are for a REV cooking closing in
on 200 th over there let's go shout out
to it then obviously I ain't going to
tell nobody in this room the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com
areu garbage it's a goddamn life changer
over there
gang [__] please please a bajillion
hours worth of content I'm not sure but
you can check it out yourself and I
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinary the old magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what up T-Bone what
up boys how are you bro I'm doing great
we got a cousin Joey on here came across
the bridge to say hello huh I'm coming
back all right I'm back brought a little
stadel for you boys that Shadell I
brought a nice uh fresh cookies over
there on the table dang the long hair
ain't lying cuz we could be more excited
that are incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he is the host of the
Juggernaut podcast he's he's a leader in
the industry the basement yard give it
up for Joe sanato everybody the kids
here look out these all unbelievable
[__] intros by the way I'm just
sitting here like I got to be better at
what I'm doing man like this is
incredible holy [__] thanks for coming
buddy minor league baseball this year
work that out a little bit yeah I mean
like I said I mean came in here I see
the new setup I'm like all right things
are going pretty well over here man
thank you buddy you're killing it man
congratulations you're doing you're
you're not too shabby yourself there big
guy not too bad it was a crazy year for
for me uh I feel like the both of us at
the same time like we we like did that
episode and then after that it was just
like oh everything's like we that's very
true we were both like kind of middle of
the road and then yeah crazy man
shopping for golf clubs
together yeah did you get a Titleist
yeah very nice and you boys are going on
the road you're hitting hitting the pike
yes we are our first show is like in
three or two days whatever the [__] it
is like three days or something I don't
know on Friday that's awesome we have
our first show I'm really excited about
that uh I I like I like delayed doing
like live shows for so long um but now
I'm like super excited for it and I get
to do it with Frank uh for the show but
yeah we're we're that's sick he's your
childhood friend yeah dude you posted a
video that almost made me cry did you
see that it's them two when they're like
four making videos and like doing what
they do now and then shows them selling
out like a 4 million person theater I
was like what the [__] is this instead
of me and you fighting in an open mic
yelling at each other over over who gets
kills on this could be
us yeah we we put that out cuz like we
we were trying to like convert the
footage because I had a old uh camera
that recorded on cassette tapes were you
that kind of you were that you were
those kids always filming or just kind
of [__] around making stuff yeah we
just like [__] around CU you know
like jackass was like popular so we're
like dude we should [__] ball up a
bunch of socks and throw them at each
other's nuts and like we just would do
[__] like that hey man when it works it
works exactly so we were like we were
doing that and then you know there was
some like sketches that we would do and
we just liked you know doing it uh and
so I I I went to this place like I had
to drive all the way out to like this
place in Jersey like pretty deep in
Jersey the most New York thing I had to
drive all the way to [__]
Jersey take the 37
minutes literally I think it was like 42
I was like 42 I was like I'm never
[__] doing this again bro this is is
terrible but such a New York thing
LOL tunnel was all backed up I hate
going to [__] Jersey dude New Yorkers
don't like it I hate I the George
Washington Bridge I hope falls into the
water and the tunnel should explode and
fill up with water I hate it all of it
sucks oh that's great yeah we used to
make videos when we were super young
though we would record a bunch of [__]
um and then like I don't know like our
friends were who when we were in high
school there was like this elective
class that they took that was like you
have to make a movie at the end of the
year sure so me and him were like oh
we'll do it we just everyone's projects
for like three years in a row um but
then he went away to college and [__]
and like I started doing like YouTube
and stuff and then we started doing the
podcast together like three years ago
and now like we get to [__] do the
thing yeah it's really [__] crazy
trying not to think about it and I do
the same after the show I'm GNA be like
that's nuts just did that yeah like all
right fine now we can celebrate uh you
got a new place mhm you got a new spot
did you buy it you're renting what are
you doing no I'm renting right now
really still renting I'm I'm I think in
the next couple of years uh I I do want
to buy like an investment property or
something I'm surprised you're going to
have four of them sharp kid like you he
is a shark probably own this
building I'm pay it's a shell
Corporation I pay every week she like
thanks so much for the rent checks by
the way guys I really appreciate it it's
going up next month about 30% tell toty
I said
hello uh but yeah no I I rent this place
but and I always like bounce around like
Apartments too and I think that's why I
haven't really like thought about buying
like anything I'm thinking about like
buying a house in the next like four
years where would that be yeah we BBS
obvious like Bish Jersey no I just said
the tunnel I'm going to blow it up yeah
that's what everybody says so they move
out there it's like find a nice place
it's a very nice backyard it's like you
can't get this anyut New Jersey or
something maybe like Westchester or
something I definitely is B definitely
not Long Island I don't want to go that
way you don't want to go out to the
island no I don't what about St nice
though Staten Island is Jersey's got a
better chance than that Jesus I like
Staten Island I've been there I'm not
kidding I've been there one time in my
life yeah it's crazy New Yorkers just
don't go or twice twice I think cuz like
why though like unless you know people
in stat Island which you don't cuz they
they never be those animals no but they
go to high school there and then they go
to the Staten Island College whatever
the [__] it's called the College of
Staten Islanders or whatever the you're
talking about like it's another planet
it literally bro one one way in one way
out it's University you got to take a
boat to get there I don't know uh yeah
I've only been I've only been a couple
of times it's been it's to-do podcast
when Chrissy Chrissy D was over there oh
yeah that's right I like it out there
though I like I like when you get over
when you get over the bridge into
because because to get to back to Philly
I would go through the city and that's
become a nightmare like you said Lincoln
Tunnel the uh the GW so I've been I've
been trying to outsmart it and go around
and go go over the verzano and then go
through Staten Island and when you get
over there you're like ah it's just all
right I'll be honest with and you're
like I'm an hour away from home it's
crazy yeah just look on Google Maps
you're like just the distance three
miles dude it's brutal when you're like
you're like I've been in the car for an
hour like I'll do I'll leave Jersey over
the GW I get to Jersey and I'll be like
I've been in the car for an hour and I
can see like I'm not even past like the
Empire State Building see see where I
left from here and I've been in the car
for a day like what the [__] is going on
kippy's got he's got the quick out in
case anything gets Jam in right at the
foot of the GW I bang a right don't call
him he ain't waiting for you he's
already made it abundantly clear look
out your window and see if the traffic
is really bad of course and I have I
have my car parked right facing to it so
if the apocalypse H dude I'm two lights
and I'm out yeah some gallons of water
and some contact lenses gone what's the
new place like is it uh without
divulging too much sure it's uh
I it's the best place I've ever lived in
but like it's super nice it's right on
the water in in Greenpoint so it's got a
beautiful view of Manhattan doorman
doorman rotating cast of doorman is that
good or bad it's bad when Christmas
comes and you're like who do I who do I
pay for this G to ask you that there was
times where I had the card ready to give
to the guy that cuz there's two guys
that I know when I go down there right
this guy Ryan and the other guy who's I
honestly I forget his name right now but
like I know those guys yeah there's
usually in a I'm imagining in a building
like that there's there's tears there's
a guy that runs the dormen and then
there's the you know the players and
usually a lot of times in the mailbox or
like at the front they'll go like hey
it's Jim like happy holidays from the
staff Jim Joe Billy Bobby Tommy so they
didn't do that and but like there's
there's a yeah there's a lot right next
to uh my building so that's where I park
my car okay and those guys like and also
this is kind of weird but like obviously
so it's a it's like a valet because you
text and then they bring your car up or
whatever and in my car was a card and it
had all of their names and but there was
like 20 names and I'm like what am I
doing with this like I'm not doing this
it's all like their brothers and stuff
so whole family the two guys who I see
all the time that work there those are
the ones that I'm like okay what do you
grease I me you said a card are we
talking gift cards here no
likeit envelope I just wrote like you
know thanks happy oh you do you go that
far he's a nice guy he's a sweet boy I
go cold cash in hand oh you just go here
you go I did something even I just did I
just did cash in an envelope no name or
anything just here you go not even
sealed get to it quick like you wanted
the track I also didn't know the
protocol with this because I'm like I
feel bad essentially having a valet
every day and I'm like I don't give them
anything like during can't have cash on
me all the time to just give people you
know what I mean yeah no those those
guys operate in like an annual or maybe
like every now and then you hit them
with something but they they operate on
an annual annual tippet yeah yeah yeah
so what you give them I G uh I got know
I gave the guy at the garage 150 bucks
that's good is that real good because I
also didn't know if that was good or bad
that's good that's that's I would say
well let me ask you this what was the
face you got did he see it or just saw
the card it was a card I put I didn't
want yeah you handed him like what you
handed him that's 100 m away I literally
I gave it to him I ran away I was like
[__] hope that's okay I'm bad with
that is that trashy to do like if I if I
leave like a like a good credit card tip
I'll say here's 40 for you yeah you do
that is that trashy if you leave a good
you wait you do a credit card tip
also I'll say it that is that bad that's
horrible I wanted to know I'm not a
scumbag that's so showing you a scumbag
but he's going to see the receipt after
I left that's so T what's the point of
doing it [__] there Joe what are you
talking about I'm face throw in here the
best would be if you go that's 40 for
you he opens it up it's
10 you like folded it up four times so
we can't read he's like it's a it's a
big one I feel like it's less about the
waiter and more about the people you're
with like that's 40 from me they didn't
throw in [__] but he's known to do that
in a group setting he separates himself
he separates himself from the rest of
the group when he picks up the check he
goes there you go and then that's he'll
tip him cash then go that's for you let
me ask you a question oh if you're at a
if you're at a if you're at like a
dinner let's say there's like four or
five people right and everyone sits down
whatever is there like what's the
protocol there is it five cards is it
two cards one we talked about this we we
have very strict rules on this big man
hit him okay uh you're talking you and
four of your boys yeah okay friends from
high school like did that matter matters
are they workers no no no it's not like
a professional set it seems every time I
go out to dinner I'm picking up the
[__] Jack if I'm being honest no but
like the four of us went to dinner like
what's the we would pick it up cuz
there's three of us I'm not going to
make you pay but who's picking it up how
many cards are there no we we have a
company card okay okay oh no okay so
something not like that yeah not a
company card thing it's like who are the
four guys are they guys you grew up with
yeah okay so they're four guys you grew
up with they your tight Squad how do
they do how do they do everyone has a
normal job can afford a din yeah yeah
okay no one's do you do the
best yeah he's the prince of patreon
what do
you but it's it's less like like it's
less about that I'm I'm more so asking
no it's about that it's about to all
right but if it's like but what you
going to pick up every every check no no
you're not going to pick up every check
you would hope that there're strong
enough dudes that okay you know say you
go out to dinner multiple times four
times in a row not in a row but like a
year like Hey Joe I have Joe got last
one then Steve gets the next one Bill
gets that one to me that's the gentleman
way to do it or if it's situation where
you you're doing much better than them n
no Joe we got it you got you got the
last two we're going to we're going to
chip in and get this one okay you're
getting stuck with a check a lot aren't
you no no actually I like like cuz I I
love restaurants and [__] like that's
where I'm willing to just be like yeah I
got it like let's just go have a good
time attitud like do whatever and I my
friends actually get mad at me because
like I that what usually happens is I
have two different friend groups where
there's two different types of [__]
happening here and one us I'll let you
know what's right and wrong baby well
it's obvious what's [__] wrong
because we have some pamphlets we can
give you on your way out too this is
this is my therapy session I'm like
listen bro this is why we started the
show do you have dirt ball friends it's
literally like sometimes people would be
like Oh I'm going to get my own check
and it's like no no you're not you're
not who says that sometimes people say
that not your squad from school no no
yeah like kids I grew up in the
neighborhood with like oh I got I get
check or like or like I had I only had
that so I'm going to and be like bro if
you sit down at this table we're
splitting the thing yeah
we're all in together regardless of
who's paying like bro your appetite has
nothing to do with how much you're
paying to be honest with you you're
paying for the seat at the table you're
sitting down at the chair like you're
[__] paying BR just to play Devil's
Advocate that might be somebody who
doesn't have it and is worried that
they're going to get that they're going
to you know get put into an embarrassing
situation I've been that guy a lot where
I didn't have it and everybody's like
let's order a $90 bottle of wine and I'm
like buddy I'm ordering [__] Bud
Lights here but that's that's your
friend's responsibility to say say no
dude you're not doing that don't worry
about that's a before you get there type
of conversation you know what I mean you
they doing this when the check comes
yeah yeah oh that's bad but like it's
not because beforehand if we could plan
for something I have a less of a problem
with that but like and are they have in
the appetizers and stuff that everyone's
sharing tasting and then all of a sudden
they're like I just had the chicken bro
Kario doesn't show up and you don't have
nothing you have a piece or two you know
what I mean that's that that's a scumbag
that's enough of the if you eat anything
you're split in the bill that's just
that's how it happens yes that's so
succinct if you eat anything you're
splitting the bill or if you don't have
it we got it you're not we're not
splitting the check after the fact yeah
that's and you just putting your entree
and your soda on there when you had
beers and you had and you know you had
the uh the barata and this and that no
we're not doing that I also don't like
like so many cards like three cards it's
crazy three too many a double dat dou
you can split hey whatever whatever it
so and or like I'm fine with the you
know I'm fine with the I got it and
someone go I'll V go sure whatever you
do it was this if you want to do it I'm
not sending a [__] request but it's
if you want to send it I'll take it it
is what it is that's what I'm I'm bad my
friends getting mad at me for that [__]
too because like I'll be like I got it
just like ven on me and then like I
don't send requests and they're like
can't send a request you can't send a
request but they you know I don't know I
don't cuz I don't mind like doing [__]
like that all the time but that the only
thing is just like oh we're going to put
five cards in I'm like bro we can we're
going to be here with this they don't
even have enough pens in this restaurant
for us to sign to get the [__] out of
here now we're all taking turn signing
[__] Declaration of Independence we all
get to sign the [__] thing you sign
your name real big
Joe uh there was also the thing too of
like then you got to do the tip well I'm
tipping 30 you're got $22 you let me
tell you something as a server that was
always my my my biggest thing cuz you
always got screwed when it was like uh
all right put put aund say say the bill
was $200 put 150 on here and 50 on the
other card and he's going to he's going
to do the tip that guy always does the
tip out of 50 bucks that sucks also I
don't I like to tip because I worked in
like a pizza I worked off of tips for
like years of my life so I usually tip
like very well and yeah that's what I'm
talking about but like if I go out on a
double date or something and it's like
know I'm about to tip something stupid
sure so and then like how much did you
tip and I'm like I don't want to say now
like in front of like a group you go I
gave I gave him 30 all sudden you're
leaving with the two
broads hey you can take the left dip 100
take it easy this episode is brought to
you by better help MH calling all you
nut jobs out there actually you know
what not even it's normalized man it's
not even that it's normalized but uh but
but this adds about relationships about
how tough it is in relationships
relationships aren't easy and when you
have talk therapy and you can talk
something out you get to work on
yourself and you get to work on your
relationship you a different perspective
of someone going ah you might have been
an [__] there or maybe he or she was
doing you just get a different a
different eyeline without clouded your
clouded emotions and we joke around a
lot here on the Pod but I'll tell you
what better help has helped me out just
the simple like you think that you got
to go all in you got to go to an office
you got to sit there you got to tell
them your information all these
paperwork help it's almost like reaching
out to a friend but it's a licensed
therapist yeah uh it's easy to get
started just fill out a quick
questionnaire get match with a licensed
therapist you can do therapy by video
call by message or even over the phone
whatever works for you so here's the
turkey become your own soulmate baby
whether you're looking for one or not
visit betterhelp.com garbage a day and
you get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com garbage do it gang go it K let's
talk about sheath shout out to sheath
and OG spons I'm talking about sheath
underwear OG from Jump Street yeah you
know what I'm talking about best
underwear in the biz yes sir you know
why why cuz it separates the nut sack
from the wiener doll so it doesn't get
all hot and sweaty down there yeah Iraqi
War veteran invent at them I know he's a
good dude I know him personally guy
shout out to [__] Robbie baby uh yeah
if you're not familiar it's a pocket for
your for your ball sack a pocket for
your wiener you can put both in one you
can Swift swap you can leave one at the
house whatever you want to
uh give it a shot it's the best
underwear you'll ever put on it's the
first article of clothing specifically
underwear but any article clothing I put
on and was like wo this is way this is a
superior product feel sex yeah you feel
you feel tight you feel like you feel
like you're in shape it makes you feel
sexy and in shape when you're not and
trust me ladies we're not I'm not uh go
to chees underwear. comom use the code
garbage you get 20% off your first order
plus sheath underwear is a one has a
100% money back guarantee that she
sheath underwear. comom promo code
garbage get sheath underwear support the
show and support your balls do it I I I
have a a question kind of in this vein I
was thinking about earlier today I
wanted to ask you have you ever had a
place like a bodega bagel shop where you
would walk in and have a usual order
you'd walk in they go oh Joey and they
knew exactly what he wanted bacon egg
and cheese or something this the worst
show to to like say this but when I was
under I think I maybe I was 20 or 21 or
something the only only place it's not
food but the only place this has ever
happened is there was a bodega where we
would buy beer from all the time so
every time we walked in there he would
say oh special for the special and then
overcharge me for like beers I was under
like that's the only time if we were
going in there especially at night he
would just be like oh he would just
start walking to the back to go get like
a [__] case of like tall boys or some
[__] respect 60 bucks like oh you're too
kind to me it's a h 100 for you he keeps
saying it's like special and it's like
the price keeps going up and I'm like I
feel like we're not saving money a
little hush money yeah exactly it's like
hey I D I'm with that though yeah yeah
the thing with the restaurant though
that's um yeah you can't have you can't
have somebody doing that I also oh sorry
and if it's again if it's the thing of
like where they don't have it it's like
dude we're not doing that we got it I'm
I I'm a fat guy too and I've I always I
what ladies and gentlemen that's just in
he like piggybacked off you with
something you did say I also a what the
hell was that man no no no that wasn't
it wasn't in
connection
Christ I'm also a fat guy with to my
stomach I'm on this soic you got me you
got me doing the gymnastics and stuff
man you hit me with an insult I was
there wasn't I wasn't pinning that
comment to you I was saying in addition
to that I me being a fat guy for most of
my life and also poor for a very long
time I always got crazy anxiety when I
would be in those situations the worst
anxiety [__] man and they start yelling
out stuff and I'm going I can't I know I
can't swing that you guys are we're
going to do we're going to do the
oysters I'm like [__] I think that's
okay too cuz like if if in those
situations like people are start
ordering and getting crazy if it's me
I'd be like I'm not [__] doing that
you know like chill and also within
[__] reason like I I've been out to
dinner with someone who has just an
unlimited amount of money basically and
I want to be and like dude takes care of
me sometimes with certain things so I
was like I I want to take you out and do
whatever so we went to uh coat the
steakhouse City expensive place very
expensive and at one point he just holds
up the menu and this is where I'm paying
right he holds up the menu and he goes
we'll do that yeah see you can't and he
went like this I was like who orders a
finger dash of food he gave you a
direction we'll do here south [__]
everything from his this this
from the neck down we'll take all the
meat you have and then this the Sam
comes over and he he he's talking to him
and then he's like yeah we'll do that I
literally texted him and I was like how
much was it the bottle you just got but
he was like no it wasn't bad it was like
60 bucks or something I was like okay
cuz like I was thinking he's got like a
thousand bottle or something yeah but is
that okay so is that is that a situation
where you said hey I want to take you
out tonight yeah because you take me out
all the time yeah I wanted to like
return the so those guys which you're it
sounds like you're slowly turning into
you're you're you're becoming that guy
as far as the pecking order not that
you're doing what he's doing but you're
becoming that guy when when they get
that you know they they want they want
to go all out a little bit but that's
just like uh that's like the same as the
bodega guy whacking you out a little bit
that's a one time thing the other thing
you were saying when people start going
crazy I have the luxury of not having
the best social life so I don't have
like Fringe you don't say I don't I
don't I don't have situations where it's
me you and Toby what are you talking
about I mean yeah I would assume that
sometimes you're going out to dinner
with like nine guys some of them are
your boys maybe a couple of their
girlfriends and then there's like some
Fringe people that you don't really know
or whatever in that situation when some
Bozo at the end of the table that you
don't know but knows you do well think
oh Joe's GNA get it and he starts doing
that then you got to put a little bit of
a kaios on it but I never really go out
to eat with people that I wouldn't like
you know go to war with I'm a loser by
on yeah I eat with a tight Circle so
when that happens it's every you know
everybody we're all eating and enjoy
yourself what however it shakes out it
shakes out I would NE like I I don't
know how it would react in the moment
but the idea of going out to dinner with
like a large group and someone at the
end of the table who I don't really know
is like oh let's get this $300 bottle of
wine I'd be like hold on yeah yeah not
Happ what the [__] are you talking
usually that's not the guy that's going
to be picking up the check or that's
going to he he doesn't have it like that
yeah you better be wearing like some
wild jewelry in order for me to like be
like all right F looks like he's going
to pay for that so uh but if you're up
there just like a regular t-shirt I'm be
like hold on we we should talk about
stuff first jewelry does that does that
necklace
spin are you in gunit by any chance and
I got to be honest you see those videos
every once in a while that pop up like
you know a girl out for her birthday or
something like that and they put it all
in the boyfriend and then the girls get
mad when the boyfriend doesn't pay yeah
those type of dinners which I haven't
had one of those since I was probably in
my like late 20s early 30s and I was a
baroke at the time those gave me such
anxiety yeah I I hated just the
situation of it I hate it I felt bad for
the waiter I just the whole thing sucked
yeah I mean I I'm definitely not like I
I I I am I hate not hate but like in
restaurants I'm very like I don't I
won't send food back I'm never going to
like for a table change gentlemen dude
never if they put me in the bathroom I'm
eatting in the bathroom that's just it
and I say this on on the show all the
time where I'm like if I ordered a
burger and they bring me a salad I'm
eating salad that really I'm gonna say
thank you and eat it because like I I
just I don't know I feel I mean that's
probably an extreme example but no but
for sure I'm I'm I get the sentiment of
it yeah but like I I I'm not there to
cause a problem or like I need a
different table or I need to whatever
like we just got unlucky tonight like
we're by the kitchen I don't know to
tell you like let me ask you this okay
an honest mistake is an honest mistake
but what if the server has kind of an
attitude oh man I don't know that I've
I've really experienced that too much
it's kind of crazy cuz every server has
an attitude with Foley for some reason
he's really been bumping heads with the
server Tru truth be told all right you
know what I mean um I am starting to get
a little uh it's your squirly older
squirly as as as T-Bone has said as
dubbed it it's your o zmi tempy he's
epic he's not eating what he's used to
and he's Furious about it oh my God and
so then when it's like did you ever see
like those people getting fights at
[__] uh McDonald's and [__] it's like
cuz they they're like addicted to it and
it's not coming out it's cold so imagine
going to your dealer's house he's just
dangling a bag in front of you and
you're like yeah [__] F so you get
all feisty when they bring you the wrong
thing listen that kid at the Wendy's
drive-thru had it
coming I don't want to hear that dragged
him through the [__] window the
[__] it I ordered a medium fry you
never like this is ridiculous when I
talking to man just kind of an normally
what you're saying no matter what they
brought I'm eating it it would take a
lot for me to say anything unless they
were a dick because I've been was a
server for so long you know what I mean
you know when someone's being a dick
yeah and it's like yeah I just uh a
little I'm I'm more of like bad attitude
I'll probably say something if it's
happening to someone I'm with like if it
happens to someone I'm with that that
yeah why don't you stick up for me you
got me sitting there like an idiot you
were
rude I as for my table to be changed sir
I'm not with him yeah I don't I don't
know and if they're rude to somebody at
of course are you are you like a jokey
guy when the check comes no what do you
mean like oh my [__] dad is like dads
are like that my dad like 50% of the
time that he gets a check he's like whoa
break a [__] window in here too
that's a pretty good one that's all
right
[Laughter]
he would say that all the time they take
the checkbook I didn't order this H am I
right no yeah that's that that's dad
stuff and he's he can't see the [__]
thing too I don't think that he can go
to a restaurant honestly because they
will hand him a check and he'd be like
can't even [__] see I too dark in
here where's the [__] lights I can't
see it anymore either really you got to
take the phone out you're not you're not
flashing the phone I don't do the the
flashlight out but I I if it's if it's
dimly lit you hover it over the yeah I
hover it over that's amazing see that
happened the other night it makes me
feel cool when that happens I feel like
I'm like going over a document like I
have like a light you know what I mean
I'm like how you doing what's that yeah
it's like a blue light you're like
trying to find a [__] the other night
we were at a place where uh where we get
you know we we get we get free drinks or
discounted drinks or whatever it is and
they handed me a check and it was like
$4 and I left the 20 yeah and but then I
couldn't see the thing but I did make
sure that I wrote the tip in first and I
said well what is that is that a six or
nine there and she's like oh it's a six
I'm like there you go that's 20 for you
okay and there you go yeah I mean that's
another thing too like when you get
hooked up at certain places it's like
now I got to tip a lot you got to you
almost like don't save money in those
situations no I lose money I'm also now
I've I I've I've
been so I've had a tip not so great for
a very long time when I didn't have the
money I was always give you something
like even if it's a do if I'm just
ordering a beer or like a pub it's like
all right I'll give you a dollar a drink
whatever here take take these
buttons those are good buttons and
that's half a cigarette for
you sh it's a pretty good pour good job
D bud it's a fist bum couldn't finish
the rest of his por job oh it's all you
big
dog man keep them coming keep them
cold uh oh man now if now like you know
we we perform you know in a lot of clubs
and stuff and if I'm getting a drink
they don't you know they don't charge it
so I'm like and I I to pay back to what
I was doing it's usually a a a 20 like
per I'm like all right here you go
that's for you that's for you not I'm
only doing one or you know the I know if
I go into a place and I hit them at 20 I
get a couple you know they're go oh do
you want to not like then they're giving
them to you type yeah you know okay
trying to create a little [__] a
little bit of buzz you know what I mean
get the people talking she like oh you
guys dishing out money over there you
better like hook them up have any of you
guys been to a restaurant that had you
try and sit at shared tables with
strangers are you nuts yeah some I mean
New York does that for for sure I don't
love it out of here what that place in
Chinatown tried to do that I was like
I'm out of here I I USA start say USA I
couldn't do it also when they have
tables that are basically shared because
you're they're on elbows are touching if
they have to move the table for you to
get to your seat what are we we're
living like are we doing we're living
like rats tables in here I'll wait I'll
wait 20 minutes I don't want to yeah a
can of sardines in here and I don't even
like because I like talking and knowing
the dude's right here like I'm the [__]
I'm saying is this guy's here and all
yeah dude my wife will be like weird I
we'll be sitting D we'll be sitting in
like a [__] Italian restaurant like
six people lyed to and she'll be like so
you guys you when do you want to start
having kids I'm like shut the [__] up
not we're not doing this here we whisper
at restaurants oh I'm I'm I'm like that
too me and my we just text each
other I like hand over the mouth what
are you going to get going get something
good I do like when it's like if you
have a bigger group you usually get a
table that's kind of way and like that I
like because then you could just it's
more of like a hang situation but when
you're in like a quiet restaurant and
it's like just you and someone else and
there's a [__] table right there it's
like well I'm not talking tonight then
we'll do sign language because I can't I
don't like feeling like people are
listening or something once they stop
talking and they're eating I'm like
they're listening I hate the people uh
and this is this is a bit of a me thing
this is a bit of a me thing I'll let
thing I I'll let external things ruin my
my dining experience
but the guy at the table call a scene
who who's talking to the person that
he's with but also like a little bit
open to the restaurant like I'll be
talking and I'm like you know I I go
over there and I like he's making eye
contact with you like talking to be
heard it's like dude shut up I hate that
also like you're on the train or
something you're just on the phone
loudly it's crazy one how's your phone
working and two what like shut the [__]
up like you're not like whisper or be
like I'll call you back when I get
outside this turned into four old guys
real quick I like it these kids how I
grew up you know that's just me though
this generation I tell you kids dancing
on the subway $4 for Gummy Bears what
are we
nuts $4 for Gummy Bears uh in this vein
a little bit uh do you have a favorite
casual dining restaurant an apple bees a
Fridays a pizzita Uno like what's the
and what would be a treat grown up that
you're that that the fan would take us
to like maybe on a Friday or Thursday
not going
anywhere have a treat it was my dude IED
I was talking about this the other day
my mom going anywhere we was like oh
we're all going out to a restaurant that
happened like graduations and like
Christmas Eve that was really Christmas
Eve Christmas Eve Christmas Christmas
Eve we used to go to this restaurant in
the city all the time my Dad's friend
like owned it that that makes sense
that's I'll give you that that's that
that's nice
Italian yes probably nice Mandarin
[Laughter]
it's like yes it is an apple piece he
owns one of the chains uh but yeah um no
yeah we never went anywhere and also for
like graduation [__] you just go to a
diner a diner a diner a diner neptun
diner if you're eating eggs in a suit
that's no good pancakes fat pancakes too
nept Diner all right yeah uh their
lobster Abyss used to be amazing for a
celebration that's crazy City kids
that's that's how they do it like a New
York city pigeon dude who does that
that's [__] crazy literally it's like
right next to the train there's birds
[__] all over the sign it's like
yeah here we going got a little mince on
the way out that was a little delicacy
love the Neptune Diner yeah and the B
air not too sh they're shutting it down
you know Neptune really yeah man there's
like four left yeah in the city yeah
there's like four good D which as a
comedian in New York City that was our
that was our homeless shelter our living
room yeah you would be with a group of
five or six people and it' be like
someone's like I can afford mozzarella
sticks and you're like well just go hang
out here and bother them for 7 hours cuz
it's raining coffee yeah um as far as a
go-to for one of those restaurants
like I don't I don't know I haven't been
in an Applebees in a long time but the
last time that I went uh we went because
like I was sitting around with like my
brother and sister and they were like
let's go get dollaritas I love it and I
was like I love it all right fine dude
we go to app black out for n bucks talk
about a gold mine of an idea listen to
this though we go to be and we're
sitting down and the guy comes he's like
oh can I get you we're like we want to
do the dollarus and like you know
whatever and he's like you don't want to
do the dollarus that's what he said what
so we didn't end up getting them cuz
he's like he's like you don't want to do
it why what was this I didn't ask us
they're probably [__] in the [__]
dollaritas though you really won't push
back at a restaurant hey I want the
chicken figures no you don't all right
I'll just take the chest oh my dude sir
I went to a nice I went to teresi nice
restaurant okay the [__] waiter
absolutely just cucked me like when it
came to dessert he's like you guys got
to get this for dessert I'm like oh yeah
I was like yo I was like that sounds
really good can I just see the menu
wouldn't even give it to you no at a
certain point I was like that would
bother me I don't like that no it drove
me nuts but [__] deserve
unbel knew what he was talking about I
was like that guy thank God he's lucky
that [__] worked out that way cuz I
would have been pissed off it was okayo
sorbet that's what you bring me dude it
was great bro this kid eats not
dude he likes it what's the name of it
oh my I I don't know what the name of
ites they do a credit check at the front
door let me get let me get a quick rund
down of the maps okay all right all
right all right hang on what second what
second and maybe prices if they're
listed yeah it's a pricey joint how do
do you have a guy that get your
reservations or are you doing it uh yeah
you have any ins you any any any can you
can you get on the Jumbotron at
MSG can you get me on can we go together
I do have a friend that that works in
the restaurant industry and he's he was
the one that I was talking about before
so for reservations for like good
restaurants and stuff like that one he
got me because like that's a that's a
difficult restaurant to get into I don't
like to do that I haven't done it in a
while with him but like I'll like if I
want to go somewhere be like hey can you
whatever he's like yeah sure do you tend
to lean towards like hip like are you
like a Carbones guy Carbones you put an
S on it carbon isn't it carbon Carbone
it's also I realized I'm so I have a I
have a cool friend who lives in New York
like he's like very restaurant and I'm
just thanks
buddy he yells at waiters all the time
I'm just very not that got like we're
just not those dud we find a decent nice
place that we like from time to time
whatever I remember the one time I felt
so cool I'm like you got to check this
place out he goes that opened nine years
ago oh [__] it's brand new I thought I
was given nobody knows about it it's
called Smith and Linsky yeah all right I
got you on some apps here hit me
cucumbers we're not splitting these by
the way cucumbers cucumber salad right
yeah new New York Cay uh 19 bucks for
cucumbers doing all right it's like this
much too not yeah okay I'm going to
sound like a real [__] trying to
read these Char part of the fun charred
clam
bu how do you spell it's an Italian
joint Char
gabble b o u l
e ah stump the crew I'd have to look at
it I'd have to look at i' have to get
eyes in front of it why don't we get a
plate of it over here we'll figure we'll
get to the bottom of it I got to look at
it in order I got to get some eyes on
this thing I can taste it blind taste
test I can tell you what it is Italian
American hams with zeppo real nice nice
sliced B's head on rye Bor head chopped
liver with
manevitz no this is crazy Cho you say
cho liver with manevitz I don't think
this is the right place manevitz is a
Jewish wine there's like a tortillini on
there that's like the thing you're
supposed to get is apparently is really
good uh not see torini but I got some
o toini talking about you're talking
about Irene torini T-Bone sounds a
little T she just had another
kid Irene torini dude really popping him
out man tbug the torini Pomodoro yeah I
think that's it yeah what what's a pasta
dish going for about 30 bucks New York
New York Hy toyy that ain't horrible
it's a it's like similar to like Carbone
prices okay have you been to Carbone
yeah good he's a cool guy he's a cool
kid I like I really like restaurants
though and I have two friends that they
they do well also and and they one of
them is like very like he's the one who
books all of them so like a lot of these
restaurants you have to like wait until
like 9:00 a.m. on a Tuesday and then
they drop the reservations for the next
month so he's all over that so we we try
to like you know do like nice
restaurants that are like either new or
whatever then yeah that's great yeah I
like I like going to places like that
like trying new [__] like if you go to a
place and it's like a nice like if it
has like a Michelin star or something
and there's something on on a menu that
I've never had before like oh let's get
that like [__] it and this was not the
case growing up from what you absolutely
going to diner for his wedding or
something he said the [__] you talking
about he was at the Neptune diner
something we've been asking people
lately which we think is a really good
tell when was the first time you had
Nutella
dude two weeks ago literally maybe I was
like 25 four 25 like I also that's an a
kid in the city that's that's pretty bad
K let's talk about blue Chu shout out to
Blue chisel let's talk about blue Chu
talking about throwing a little gas on
the fire you know what I mean gang do
yourself a favor it's 2024 baby don't be
shy you need a little help in the boir
yeah get blue chew pop on in chewable
same ingredients as seis look out she
won't know what hit her uh they come in
these uh chewable tablets just pop one
30 to 60 minutes before getting down and
dirty and you you should know by then
that you hey I see you know I have
troops am M aline the Border this is
about to happen that's right after the
entree before you order
dessert uh you can take it anytime and
it's uh it's easy to get a prescription
just sign up at bluechew.com talk to one
of their licens medical providers
providers and you'll get a prescription
within days baby blue chw wants you to
have better sex and with bluechew you
will yeah discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and do it baby uh
and the good folks over at Blue Chu we
have a special right now for are you
garbage listeners you can try blue Chu
for free when you press in the code
garbage at checkout there you go just
five bucks for shipping that's all five
five bucks for hardons what are we doing
here that's crazy uh that's blue.com
promo code garbage a
boner it's less than a cup of coffee
you're getting laid uh it's bluechew.com
promo code garbage to receive your first
month for free visit blue.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank thank Blu for sponsoring
the Pod now back to the show back to the
show dude I didn't even know what
avocado was until I was like at least 19
years old I'm serious I didn't have it
till mid 20s and I was still unsure
about it I like what is this [__] like
avocado and it came out of nowhere
avocado toast like that [__] started
booming I remember the first time I
found feta cheese good night it was a
[__] dude it became a line item on my
monthly expenses the second I found that
I was putting that [__] in everything so
good man I love
when it's in my fridge I'll just like
pop open the little container take a
crumble and start my day with some fet
yeah literally I'll just put it in like
a Zin just right in
your just let it just let it melt
throughout the day I'm thring a six
milligrams of [__] feta over here
jump on the computer and get to work oh
that's great all right so no Nutella
okay uh and these are these are some um
uh when you when when do you put your
deodorant on you put the shirt on then
deodorant or deodorant then shirt and
what are you banging with dude you guys
are going to love this you're rolling
your no deodorant don't wear deodorant I
don't smell think I might have
remembered that now I don't smell yeah
it's crazy like I like there definitely
is a smell sometimes okay you really you
really caved on that P I don't smell at
all except most of the time I FedEd
cheese yeah that shit's coming out of
you yeah but like like it's like not
like it's not enough to like when I wake
up in the morning or the end of the like
I just don't like nothing comes out when
are you showering you showering at night
or in the morning um I kind of like it
it really depends mostly in the morning
because like that's the only time that I
really like work out is in the morning I
can't work out in the afternoon after is
that your workout routine you get up in
the morning and and you go to the gym
yeah you hit the gym in the in the
apartment yeah kid keeps it tight yeah
but like and then you have sh after that
you got a lot of money take me to the
diner that's a sharp fade you can open a
letter on that thing yeah who's cutting
a hair let me get it with you rich the
barber he's in uh what is that
[__] uh Jackson Heights okay okay
what are you tipping him what's that
cost and what are you tipping him uh
going out to Jackson Heights to get your
haircut he also has a place in Brooklyn
too but I I started going to him he come
to you at all ever no no no those are
like if you're going to do like a house
call it's like crazy okay but like uh he
I started going to him like years ago
but I was still living in Queens at the
time so it wasn't that far it was like
10 minutes from where I was um but then
he also has a place in Williamsburg but
he only he's only there on Tuesday so I
try to line up on my [__] you know
High Chris with Tuesdays but sometimes I
can't so I have to go to [__] Queens
man your kids love their haircuts really
love their what's the rotation how many
how many go once a week no no no no uh I
every two weeks there's no way you're
going longer than that sometimes like I
like it's probably around two weeks that
I that I do it or like you know I'll go
months yeah without getting my haircut
months you got a long hair yeah you
can't you can't have that haircut and go
M I've had that haircut and just I just
deal with it just let it grow just let
it go yeah I I went it turns into the no
haircut haircut that's a tough look just
starts growing like you know what I mean
Dad I I went to his house like during
the pandemic once and he cut my hair
outside yeah I went to his and he had
like a shield mask and like I had to
wear a mask and we're outside and and
just in his driveway and he got my hair
awesome this is like not in like the
very beginning of it like I definitely
like just buzzed my head at some point
and sure whatever um okay hold on so no
deodorant what what other are we doing
moisturizer we doing anything like that
I am doing moisturizer uh aino do aeno
that's it um but I I literally was just
talking about this on on the basement
yard about like I was like I need like a
[__] routine you know what I mean and
I was saying I was like you know white
people we age like a sidewalk like
eventually it's you start cracking and
there's like all this stupid [__] and
bad man it's like overnight you're like
I look pretty
good [__] I'm 49 years old now what's
going on but then I but then uh I was
talking enough [__] about it that a
company reached out to me and we're like
oh we'll send you some stuff it's the I
forget the name of it but it's like a
French it's like like okay oh uh L Ro
Pro L Ro Pro I pulled that cuz I was at
Tommy post last night and it was above
the thing and I read it take that torini
huh holy cow yeah that's crazy this guy
yeah when I saw you I think it was in
San Francisco we were getting ready for
the show we're like showering doing all
stuff with the Airbnb yeah he comes
walking down with the with the with the
gummies on his thepad I was like I'll
from time to time but I do listen
between what that do what I don't know
what they do feel
nice OT emotionally it helps a lot I
still look like I got punched in both
eyes yeah I do the under eye cream I do
the the the the oils the Mast all that
stuff the um exfoliators yeah I got to
start doing that sounds like a sports
team the Houston exfoliators next up for
the exfoliators lost the
championship uh Tommy Pope looks like
he's got it going on though like he's
been been putting it together for a
while he runs a tight ship he runs a
tight selfcare ship looks like he does
yeah um okay one more to uh say you're
getting into a regular shower right it's
like a bathtub shower like it's like a
tub and the shower heads on the one side
it's just a what you're saying like you
say you're at a hotel and that's what it
is right okay will you get in at the
back or will you get in the head the
side the water's coming out God that's
such a good question man I think I get
in the front like where the yeah whoa
nice you just jump into the water like
that oh no no I've let it run you let it
run and then where do you get in oh I
get in in the in the water I think get
in the front this is such a good
question you get in the back news for
you it's only me and you
dog this question like 50 people
everybody else gets in the back you get
in the back and then step you turn the
water on close the curtain or what the
door turn the water on the water's
running you put your hand in there get
it to Temp and then you go to the back
and enter the water I'm
that that might be true I do like to
walk water you know could never AR I
think I think I just going in like a
middle line the front yeah literally
yeah I could never articulate it until
now for some reason but I think the
reason that I do do that is because when
I was a kid everybody had anxiety and
getting burned by the water was a big
thing you're going to get scalded by the
water so when you get in the front you
have access to make a quick move if it's
scald and hot that's that's a good point
also I'm used to being scolded I I
there's photos of us being children
we're all in the tub and and then like
we stand up and half our bodies are just
beat was cooking us nobody was taking
temps back Mom it's hot she like shut
the [__] up she's dropping in onions and
carrots like bunny she got a ladle and
she's like shut up like you're Bugs
Bunny you better not tell your
father huh uh this is something that
we've been asking people uh who is the
most famous person you met when you were
younger and they couldn't it didn't
necessarily have to be famous but
somebody where you were like ious to you
Ernie and AZ or somebody like that neor
hood or something was there anybody a
sports player a
newscaster meet a Nick or a Yankee I I
met well I guess like I went to this
thing like Magic Johnson was like at the
NBA Store so my friends took the bus and
we went to the city and we met Magic
Johnson that's not bad that's all right
that's good a pretty good one yeah I
have assigned basketball somewhere in my
mom's house by Magic Johnson really
really waiting for him to Kel over so I
can moost that
thing
it's going to be worth something one day
I was waiting for you to be like my
uncle had a Cadillac pretty big he was
kind of known in the
neighborhood I don't know that I ever
like met someone like when I was super
young that wasn't like that like that
you go out of your way to me but like
running into a celebrity I don't think
so like we were friend like my family
was friends with like local like a local
radio DJ and that was like the that was
like the biggest thing to like oh so and
so might be there type my dad knew a guy
who owned a Hampton house
and I stayed there for a weekend and
that was
nice watched Italy win the World Cup in
that house it was nice man that's the
most New York Italian thing I ever heard
in my life at of Hampton to watch Italy
play your parents always had one friend
that did really well usually didn't have
kids or anything like that it was always
fun going over there and always always
for me it was uh uh you only only ever
did those things once it wasn't like it
was like we would go the kids would
close the scene and got like all right D
ain't coming back you got you got your
one shot yeah yeah yeah holy [__] my dad
had uh one of his commanders in the Navy
had had like a like a real prosperous
business outside of the Navy but he was
still in the Navy and he had this house
down in like Kate May down the shore or
something like that and he had was like
on the water he had a like a little boat
and like took us out and all that stuff
man I think we were like smacking
turtles in the water something like that
never got invited back again I never
threw the fishing rod in the water I I
was
I only got on a plane once when I was
like like before the age of 18 or 19 I
at one time same when Disney World and I
think I told you guys last time like my
dad did like a construction go job and
the guy paid him in Disney tickets oh
yes that's right right so that was like
the vacation that we went on yeah that's
not a great vacation what' you call your
grandparents Grandma Grandpa Grandma
Grandpa what you call the remote growing
up the remote you you clicker or
something that I was never click clicker
no we clicker some people say buttons
and stuff like pass me the buttons tough
no that's rough mash the buttons have
you upgraded the um
the aftermarket amenities in the
apartment in this in this new place like
do you got like an air purifier they got
like uh you know what are you working
with over there any kitchen appliances
do they have an automatic pepper grinder
air do not I do not I don't love that to
be honest with I don't it either I like
to grind it I like I like to feel it I
like I like to feel it because it makes
you feel like I'm a chef you
know yeah exactly like that to me is
like so much better than just like I
like [__] that that go back to feta the
first time they ran out of the crumble
go back to F I had to I had to buy the
brick you know oh I man chopping that up
I felt like [__] Chef ramsy dude I
was like no one can tell me [__] you
have your fingers you're like I know
what I'm doing I'm curled in
[__] like an old woman in Sicily
growing up did any of you guys have the
the hand crank cheese grinder you know
what like they have it like Olive Garden
uh sometimes yeah yeah yeah no there's
like a less fancy one yeah I know you
never I don't think that we had that but
I did have uh the um we we just used a
[__] like cheese grater which that
also makes me feel like a chef too I'm
just like you're talking about look at
all this cheese I the triangle one yeah
yeah that thing's deadly dude you take
your knuckles off you're not done that
like the cheese slips and you're like I
just cut the whole [__] hands but you
know what's really nice they have the
one now where it has the handle and you
oh woo feel like Bobby fle oh it's just
a stick it's like a like a fork but it's
just the long F that looks like a big
nail file oh my god dude and you then
you like tap it you you feel it you're
like good yeah I see the all in there
you're finishing you're finishing the
dish which is very nice oh that's the
best thing you you cook you cook a meal
and then you just you have some
something on top that you can be like
here just put a little bit little lemon
zest something there you go like chives
whatever the [__] that is it's a bowl of
mac and cheese yeah it's just my
cereal I'm grinding Cocoa
Puffs yeah just a dusting of the
marshmallow yeah I'm like that with
cocktails now I got really into [__]
like making cocktails uh in in the past
like few months so like I like would go
out and like buy you have a Tor you want
a torch like no no no I don't have you
got the big ice thing now to make the
ice ball or whatever yeah yeah I have
like a a thing to well not that not the
Ice Bowl I just have like the the
[__] big cubes big cubes in the in
the fridge but I also have like dried
out [__] apricots lemons and [__]
yeah like little [__] uhon sticks and
[__] like thaty cherries and all that
exactly I like that that's great when
you want to drink in 48 minutes [__]
that dude that's the word you ever order
I'm like I get a Manhattan dude they
bust out a torch I'm leaving you're at
the house you're making nice cocktails
how many of those do you make until it
turns into just whiskey on
ice not many like you're going to you
make the first one nice the second one
you're a little the second one you're a
little drunk so you're guys this is fun
the third one is just [__] out of the
bottle yeah it's like I'm just literally
going to have some whiskey and that's
pretty much it I like making it for
other people you know it's more of like
an outward thing it's more of a showof
thing you're like you what do you need
oh yeah no problem here are you
entertaining I'm double straining [__]
that doesn't need to double straining
little gra parmesan on it for you
exactly [__] like that have you had
people over the house yet the new house
like a housewarming party or was it just
like a couple people over no I I had
people over for like Memorial Day
weekend like because there's like a
little Courtyard and it has like an
awesome view so you you can like rent
out one of the uh grills or whatever got
so you so I had some people over me like
did did you grill did you man the grill
I did not oh man you invited people over
to work that's who' you have who who
cooked uh my bud it was Bobby fle dude
it was
Carbones it was Jimmy Carbones of
Carbones thing no it was one of it was
one of my friends like so he did the
cooking you did you made the drinks and
all that stuff you buy all the stuff
yeah I I I didn't buy all like I tell
people like I'm going to have stuff um
but you could bring like whatever you
want like and usually I think that's
like standard track you can't have
nothing be like b y o b it's like this
isn't a [__] yeah you got have
something not a [__] College house
party dude
you you have an apartment like have some
drinks here five bucks for a cup ex
write your name on your
cups this was all in the this was all
out in the common area this wasn't in
the apartment was it uh it started in
the apartment and then it went down
there okay anybody acting a not a fool
but a little sloppy with like knock it
off I just moved in here the coaster
placements anything like that honestly
there wasn't but I'm sure that if I was
less drunk I probably would have had
complaints you would have noticed things
but like I don't know for the most part
like shoes off in the house yeah you
have everybody got to take their shoes
off not not all the time but like
definitely like I'll encourage that like
if we're s if we're going to like watch
the game or something at my house i' be
like all right take the [__] [__]
though if you're having a bunch of
people over would you ever do a premix
cocktail like a like a jugg and julips
or something like that nice that's real
my cousin does that every Christ
probably that's probably a smart thing
to do I haven't done that but like I
don't know like I if I know that people
are coming over I'll ask them ahead of
time like when they're like 10 minutes
out like what do you want and then I'll
have it so that's like ready 10 minutes
out wow that's pretty good so they get
in there you got the [__] aot dusted
whatever exactly you got some time in
there you got a nice little that's not
bad well it's like I have to Triple
strain if you need to could double
triple strain I could do whatever could
do an egg wash or something uh you're
not doing that you no no no but like I
I'm also not the best food host
so like I'm not I picked up on that you
made another guy Grill at your party
dude that's crazy hey you want to have a
barbecue a real nice cocktail and some
Scoops you guys yeah someone else has
got to handle like the Sherie board or
whatever but I can't be doing that my
dad used to do that too growing up
that's probably why because he'd be like
oh you you want a hot dog I'd be like
yeah he goes make me want
to I'm I don't want it now that's that's
awesome uh all right let's get into some
[__] uh some patreon questions guys
when you know uh when you sign up for
the patreon we'll answer your garbage
question on the air uh we get a lot of
submissions but patreon gets the first
crack at it baby uh let's see here this
one I've never thought of this is from
kippy's denim jacket shout out to it uh
$10 Discover Card homie are you garbage
if you shower with your dog o that's
nuts but well
it's efficient it's efficient but then I
feel like you'd have to wash them get
them out and then get back into to rinse
all yeah 100% cuz the dog's going to
shake and get all that [__] all over you
but then if you just let him out he's
just shaking in the thing then the the
bathroom's disgusting that also might be
a like a swimsuit job yeah yeah you
can't be hanging dong next to the dalti
like you can't do that get of here I
never thought of that yeah you can't be
naked in that hanging brain what if
something happens yeah you can't you
can't do that that makes sense yeah yeah
so I don't think I think it's like
efficient you can do it especially like
if you have a dog that's like big
cuz if you can't put it in a sink where
are you going to put it yeah that's a
real dog person right there too I'll
tell you they love their puppy dog I
mean we do it in the tub but it's like
it's a thing yeah you got to take bands
with the dog I don't take bands with
them but like you wash them in the tub
yeah but typically someone's got to get
in there someone's in the tub someone's
out of the tub distracting with lunch
meats but hold on kind of like kind of
like how we bathe you from time to
time knew there was something going on
toini out there you
go throw me to do anything for a plate
of tortois wait you're standing in the
tub you're not like sitting down with
them no typically typically the bird
will get in there playing tummy sticks
with them no yeah no she's like holding
them and yeah it's a it's a two- main
job yeah I got you nzi don't like the
water U but I would never shower with
him that's [__] I like that that's
bunk it makes sense it does make sense I
don't think my dog would like like
showering and he'd be looking at like
what the [__] are we doing kids weird
hey bro your balls are dripping on me
what the [__] is going on what is that
thing first he makes me a drink now I'm
in the
shower talk going hey pal a little room
for the shooter huh back
[Laughter]
up H okay you this is from gugger champ
2000 is it garbage to drink the beers
that were left in the fridge when I
moved into my new place yes that's nuts
he said insane he said he had to Google
expiration dates on them if it goes bad
oh I was like Google an expiration date
man I've done that though I've dranken a
lot of expired beer in my life I feel
like yeah I think that's what you would
get a young age and [__] like special
for the special by the way all expired
uh that is insane though I would never I
would no nothing anytime I move in
everything gets [__] out you get into
an Airbnb or something like that and
like they still have like the catchup
and the mayna like that I'm not doing
that I don't trust people's [__] even
like growing up going to my friends's
houses and stuff I'd be like you got a
catchup in here from 2008 what are we
doing here I can I can I can look at a
condiment bottle and be like I ain't
touching that even if it's like my I'm
like dude that there's too much crust
the lid's been open something's wrong
God get your act together your ketchup
just looks like it's like got its period
or something it's like it's got just
like bro this thing you're an adult hot
sauce is real bad hot sauce dries bad a
lot of times the lid stops closing and
[__] you're like [__] you got to shake
the hot sauce up see if everything falls
down if it doesn't get out yeah it's a
tough look run for your lives uh this
seems like a New York thing uh this is
from Felix uh never had one read is a
garbage to move furniture on public
transportation yes I've seen it a bunch
in this I've seen people move in a love
seat onto the A train yeah and then not
even sit in it like they stood there I'm
like you're a [__] jerk off dude I I
don't know that I like I don't know have
you ever had to move anything crazy on
the train you ever had a mattress on top
of the car I definitely I've had that
yeah I've had a mattress on top of the
car um I've never done that oh man we
always had an access to a pickup truck I
remember my parents my dad always had
like a like a van or a truck he had a
work truck for so long so anytime you
were moving anything in the back there
but then you got to you know also a
pickup truck in New York is like that's
like one of the hottest Commodities you
can come across a car let alone a pickup
truck [__] that's all
right uh all right let's see here this
one's from Kevin longtime listener first
time caller is it garbage to know
someone who's been on Dog the Bounty
Hunter that's worse than Jerry Springer
for some reason for some reason I don't
know but it's pretty cool sitting down
watching it together I'll tell you that
the Bounty just's just telling it like
it's wait was he the Bounty I don't it's
it's either that or a guy who's like he
went over there yeah way less cool
either way you're in a bad neighborhood
yeah I just picture an uncle showing a
kid like I zigged I should have zagged
right he's where he got me that's he got
me he where he got me that's I thought I
had him here but you dog doesn't go
after White Collar criminals he's watch
the episode of was going no I don't know
Steven he's like I did know
Steven I was lying though totally fooled
him look at him he was in my closet the
whole time had to smoke with him out
front and
everything yeah all right let's see this
is from DJ knuckle Puck are you garbage
if you use the word the before a medical
diagnosis like I got the lupus or I got
the
diarrheas I got the diarrhea yeah yeah
that's something my dad does too my dad
also like can't he does know the name of
anything he like I remember back in the
day like Twitter was like a thing and he
was just like calling it like what you
on your [__] whatever the [__] TW [__] I
like you know what it's [__] called
like you know what you're doing right
now but that one was tough for that
gener that parents at Twitter Twitter
because it was also Twitter and tweet
Facebook was at least like Facebook I'm
going to Facebook we're on Facebook the
Twitter and tweet really threw the the
the grown-ups through a [__] tweeting on
Twitter yeah really [__] Jam them up
yeah really jammed them up yeah it's
just too close to [__] so you know yeah
the diabetes the oics you you you're big
on the you started you've reached an age
where you started putting 's on things
which is nuts yeah
Carbones oics I was going to ask this
obviously really far away but I thought
about this on New Year is it Happy New
Year's no or happy New Year happy New
Year happy New Year I've been saying New
Year's my everybody I know Happy New
Year do you say Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day Valentine's Day no times
times some people say times Valentine's
Happy Valentine's Day Valentine you're a
[__] idiot it's like you can't read
dude get out of here please stop uh my
dad puts e r instead of a on word so he
said like Winder and Victoria over at
the wind yeah yeah yeah a [__] win
Soder yeah Soder do Soder yeah hard aost
thing too voder like voder and tonic is
Boston they vodka is insane
VOD that's I hate when drunk a vodka drk
VOD I have a friend one time he ordered
let me get a Grey Goose and vodka I was
like you're
F bartender was just like I don't even
know how to make what you're clearly
underage it's just a CIA test what are
you grilling me for Jameson and whiskey
make it snappy thank
you and can I have it on the rocks with
ice please all right we got to wrap it
up ladies and gentlemen Mr Joe sanado of
the basement yard podcast Titan of the
industry here with us today thank you
guys so much for having always a good
time we love you anything you want the
folks out there to know anything else
you got to hit them with uh go to the
basement yard.com we're going to be
listing more uh tour dates for the live
shows and stuff and uh oh that's my
camera and uh you can go follow the show
at the basement yard on wherever the
[__] just type it in you'll see it
somewhere yeah you'll find it there you
go Kippy what do you got for him uh
tickets are on sale right now we're at
New York City we're doing Town Hall
we're getting ready to announce the rest
of our tour dates for the spring and the
summer uh so hit the link l in the
description if it's still there let us
know what cities we got to come to we
love you gang we love you we'll see you
next week peace